so uh because
the film's going on patreon and not
not freely available it
uh i'm talking merely to everybody
whoever is out there
in the world watching it and it doesn't
matter what style you're doing
i haven't i haven't purposely made the
camera so that
you know you can you can see my footwork
the sheer naggies the
ekos the ton of ingredients because
whatever style of aikido you do
all i wanted you to do is keep the
string
torch so so the idea of whoever sees
this film
is to watch what the string is doing
do your own techniques
sensitivity
personally i think you should do more
breathing exercises if you don't know
any
she comes very good
and they teach you tai chi perhaps from
a shaolin master on youtube
get some good instruction when your
whole body feels
the the chi or the coke you the breath
you know
is the sensitivity that this person
feels i'm going to do
two technique two movements the same and
this person will
feel the difference
and it might not be seen
on the camera
the last technique we'll do is
[Applause]
so my partner has to really work out how
much this is moving
it's very subtle this one because you're
making an arm
that will be tight there if i if my body
is too late
if i have coke you inside me or the
breath of chicken or whatever you want
to call it
the expansion feel the difference
but without the breath
the string is not full that's only what
i can explain it
without the breath the string is not
full even though it's taut
with the breath the breath is full